dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly if a here we have
talked about fluid and cloth simulations
earlier but we never really set foot in
the domain of hair simulations in the
series to obtain some footage of virtual
hair movement simulating the dynamics of
hundreds of thousands of hair strands is
clearly too time-consuming and would be
a flippant attempt to do so if we do not
wish to watch a simulation unfold with
increasing dismay as it would take hours
of computation time to obtain just one
second of footage we have to come up
with a cunning plan a popular method to
obtain detailed real-time hair
simulations is not to compute the
trajectory of every single hair strand
but to have a small set of strands that
we call guide hairs for these guide
hairs we compute everything however
since this is a sparse set of elements
we have to fill the gaps with a large
number of hair strands and we
essentially try to guess how these
should move based on the behavior of
guide hairs near them essentially one
guide hair is responsible in guiding an
entire batch or an entire braid of hair
if you will this technique would like to
call a reduced hair simulation and the
guessing part is often referred to as
interpolation and the question
immediately arises how many guide hairs
do we use and how many total hair
strands can we simulate with them
without our customers finding out that
we are essentially cheating the selling
point of this piece of work is that it
uses only 400 guide hairs and leaning on
them it can simulate up to a total
number of 150,000 strands in real time
this leads to amazingly detailed hair
simulations my goodness look at how
beautiful these results are not only
that but as it is demonstrated quite
aptly here it can also faithfully handle
rich interactions and collisions with
other solid objects for instance we can
simulate all kinds of calm being or
pulling our hair out which is what most
researchers do in their moments of great
peril just before finding the solution
to a
difficult problem not only hair but a
researcher simulator if you will the
results are compared to a full space
simulation which means simulating every
single hair strand and that is exactly
as time-consuming as it sounds the
results are very close to being
indistinguishable which was not the case
for previous works that created false
intersections where hair strands would
erroneously go through solid objects we
can also stroke bunnies with our hair
models in this truly amazing piece of
work these episodes are also available
in early access for our patreon
supporters we also have plenty of other
neat perks I've put a link in the
description box make sure to have a look
thanks for watching and for your
generous support and I'll see you next
time